petit homme
comment va votre frère laurent c'est un
petit peu difficile
plusieurs équipes ça va très bien il va
et vient de réaliser un making of pour
le l'enregistrement d'un album d'iam de
tous sortir il sait bien on a commencé
l'écriture d'un film qu'on aurait écrire
qu'il va réaliser
il a réalisé un court métrage aussi et
il a pris trois kilos
tout va très bien c'était la question ci
dessus ça va c'est pas ce qui se passe
dans le dur ainsi un jeu à temps ah bon
génie aura des sévères mais je trouve
qu'il convient il faiblit en tout c'est
pas la bonne question
enfin bon je suis désolé pour talent
titoff et la metiss du cost comment elle
va ben je l'appelais le soir elle
voulait pas me dire où elles étaient 1
est derrière et j'entendais la télé
j'entendais aussi des gens qui avait
chez elle apparemment il entendait une
voix qui disait est ce que tu penses que
sucer c'est tromper
trop dur mais on savait pas trop dur